Speaker 1: Three of the big public January six
select committee hearings have occurred, and
one of the big questions people are asking amidst
all of this is, Sir, any chance Trump will be held
legally responsible for the actions he took,
namely his attempt to overturn a free and fair
election and keep himself in power? I cover
the story that we're about to talk about on my
own show. You can find it by just searching Luke
Beazley on YouTube, or if you're watching this on
YouTube or listening to the podcast, it will be in
the descriptions. You can just click a link, it'll
take you there. Or like I said, search my name
Luke based on YouTube. And then David likely also
covered this when it came out, but I thought it'd
be really interesting to look at in the context
of these hearings and all the revelations that
have come out. To take another look at this. So,
quote, a former federal prosecutor who served for
more than 24 years in the District of Columbia's
U.S. Attorney's Office says Donald Trump could
be arrested or indicted on just the evidence
included in Monday's bombshell legal ruling by
US District Court Judge David O. Carter So now
describes that legal ruling, Judge Carter's
findings by a preponderance of the evidence,
which says more likely than not that Trump
committed felony offenses is a higher evidentiary
standard than the one needed to arrest and
indict Trump for his crimes, which requires
only probable cause. Judge Carter on Monday
wrote, Based on the evidence the court finds,
it's more likely than not that President Trump
corruptly attempted to obstruct the joint session
of Congress on January six, 21. In response, legal
experts are calling his ruling striking massive,
monumental and historic. So this was a ruling
about John Eastman, whether or not he had to
turn over documents to the January 6th committee.
But as you saw in there, this judge is saying
it's likely there's enough evidence to indict
Trump on criminal charges. That's insane.
But obviously, the big question is, is it likely.
Okay, we can talk about while he should be,
but is this actually is going to happen? And at
this point, I think David Paxton's assessment
that we probably shouldn't be expecting to
see Trump do the perp walk is still correct,
unfortunately, in the country we live in. Powerful
people are rarely held accountable to this extent.
And actually, there's some other reasons for
why Merrick Garland might be timid. And there
are legitimate reasons. I don't think there
are enough for him not to go through with it.
But I read this op ed by The New York Times
that made a case for why it wouldn't be so
crazy for Merrick Garland to be really, you
know, soft and timid on this particular issue.
And while I think it's it's wrong in its
assessment, like regardless of the backlash,
regardless of the political claims that will
be made, we should follow rule of law. If Trump
committed crimes, he needs to be held criminally
responsible. But I do understand how scary and
wild it is to think about the aftermath of
something like this. If Trump was indicted.
The riots, the insane mayhem that would happen.
I mean, that is something to be feared for sure.
But they can't scare us away from doing what
is right, which is holding Trump accountable
if he committed crimes. Of course. I'm not a legal
expert. I would want the legal experts, of course,
to analyze and see not just what Trump did, but
compared to the law. How did he clearly break it?
And if he did, he needs to be held responsible.
It's also really horrible to think about the
potential where the the potential world
where Trump has unsuccessfully prosecuted.
And for the rest of time, he's just so bolstered
in his claims that this is also political. And
he's been correct the whole time that this
was all a witch hunt. I don't like thinking
about that hypothetical. So I think behind
the scenes, Merrick Garland needs to make a
really strong case or see if he can make, based
on the evidence, a really strong case. And if
he can't, don't pursue it. But if there is
a clear laws, he violated actions. He took
evidence to prove it, then he needs to
go through with it. Maybe he, you know,
appoint a special prosecutor to do that process.
But beforehand, he needs to see if there's
such clear, hard evidence that this would be an
undeniable case to prove. And you honestly wish
that we would be in a country where people could
look at this evidence and look at the actions
that Trump took and change their mind. You know,
like all of these people on the right, I wish they
would just watch the January six hearings with
an open mind and not think that this is all fake
news. Because a lot of this is so clear what Trump
did. And if they believed he did what he did,
you would hope they would no longer want to
support him. I don't know. Maybe they're also just
not for democracy. But hopefully you believe the
only reason that they support this anti-democratic
behavior is because they think it's saving the
democracy because it was stolen from Trump. Right.
Just to kind of close it is interesting. A
majority of Americans do support indicting Trump,
actually, but it's 54%. So it's not like the whole
country or anything. The survey found that 54% of
respondents backed the idea of the Department
of Justice indicting the former president over
the Capitol riot compared to 37% who oppose the
suggestion. Obviously, and I'll say this many
times, it needs to come down to the evidence.
Can the DOJ make an undeniable case that Trump
violated certain laws? Here they are, and here's
the evidence of those violations. And if they can,
then he should absolutely be prosecuted. Let me
know in the comments what you guys think should
be curious to hear. Likely. Unlikely. Give me
your assessment. Definitely in the comments.
Thank you so much, The David Pakman
Show for having me. Guest host today.
You can check out my channel if you're
watching on YouTube or listen to the podcast
just by going to the description and clicking
the link. It'll take you to my channel.
Or if you're coming from another place,
just search Luke Beasley on YouTube or
Luke Beasley on any podcasts and platform
and just go to find my show. You are device.